[Music]
all right 2200 this is gonna be a
serious game
okay so
we're gonna play serious openings let's
play e4 e5
all right brad is already stumped
i have three knight c6 bishop c4 acceler
um sorry to dragon where did that come
from italian
there's two main moves here
as i'm sure most people know bishop c5
and knight f6
the move that i've been consistently
recommending in the speed run the move
that i've played over the board recently
is knight f6 which allows the fried
lover so
if you're playing knight f6 you have to
know first and foremost the bride liver
d4 is
uh another viable sideline for white
that you have to know so this is the
transposition to the italian i think
it's called the scotch gamut technically
the scotch gambit after e5 so if white
plays e5 here
it's the scotch gambit
in this position you can actually move
the knight so like knight g494 are
legitimate alternatives
but you know there is a move that you
have to know here
which is considered to be the most
reputable by far
and that is
d5 which is
pretty common in
you know it is most commonly known in
this position but it's an idea that
exists elsewhere as well
and now
there's a crossroads so traditionally 94
has always been considered essentially
the only move 94 is the main move
was always considered
far superior to
all of the other lines but recently i
stumbled on a really interesting
alternative which has become
quite popular in recent years and that
is knight back to d7
which on its face doesn't
you know might not seem like bad or good
it's just another move it's it's a
retreating move
now it basically covers the covers the
pin so knight takes d4 is not effective
here
if white plays knight takes d4
well first of all we can take the pawn
on e5 but we can also even take the
knight on d4 and then just go c6
so what white has to do here is play
bishop take c6 i'm hoping that brad
might not be quite as familiar with this
line
and i'll be able to take him out of
theory now full disclosure i don't
really know the theory that well myself
i know a couple of moves here but that's
about it
okay so we'll see what brad comes up
with here
bishop takes c6 is
the only move that i'm familiar with
okay brad castles
i i suppose that's also possible and
maybe even a transposition to
the main line
okay so we need to develop obviously we
need to develop
i think some people might be inclined to
play a6 here but that's a completely
unnecessary waste of time
because remember
white is very likely to take on c6 on
their own volition so a6 would
essentially
you know
compel way to do what he wants to do
anyway
so i don't really like bishop before i
feel like the bishop on b4 would be very
very loose
bishop c5 is interesting
but if we consider bishop c5 after
bishop takes c6
bc
knight takes d4
as you'll see uh if we go down the main
line
it is actually quite important to have
the c5 square open
for a pawn we want to be able to play c6
c5
once this uh trade occurs so we're going
to play bishop out to e7
maybe not the most principles i i don't
know if castles is an inaccuracy
compared to bishop c6 but
if brat takes on c6 we basically
transpose to
uh we basically transpose to the main
line
hopefully everything so far making
reasonable amount of sense
yeah brad is good
so
[Music]
again a crossroads here i suppose for
white he's got to decide whether to take
on c6 or to take on d4 or to play a
neutral move such as rookie one
but if i were white i i i don't really
see
you know the reason to delay bishop
takes c6
and knight takes d4
okay well brad's taking taking his time
and plays knight bd2 which i like seeing
that doesn't seem like a dangerous move
not sure exactly why
brad is holding off on bishop takes c6
now first of all it's important to
establish that we cannot take on e5
because after knight takes c5
no matter which way we capture we're
going to be pinned in the end
so what should we do here
how should we unpin ourselves well again
not
some people's instinct is to play a6 but
we don't need to do that the better move
is to castle
because that's a helpful developing move
as well rookie one
okay
so brad defends the pawn
let me think for a second here
all right i think an idea is
crystallizing
in my mind it's a pretty risky idea
but i think a very interesting one and
if it works out
um i think we might be able to punish
white for
for not uh taking on c6 and taking an e5
in time
so how do i explain this move well if
you look at this position from a general
perspective the most annoying thing to
me about the position is the presence of
this pawn on e5 right this pawn is
hanging over our entire position
it's cutting off some arteries it's
cutting off main street like we cannot
get anything to the sixth rank it's a
problem
so we have
oh we actually have
perhaps an even cooler move
yeah so from that perspective the idea
that i have is to play f6 and try to
remove this pawn from the board
essentially at all costs
the other really interesting movie could
make and this is typical for this
position is knight d to b8 back to b8
in order to reinforce the other knight
on c6 and open up the pathway for the
bishop which and it's not as crazy of a
move as it appears
but in this case i think f6 is more
concrete
and it just seems a little bit juicier
if you will
so let's go with f6 now some of you are
probably thinking okay what about e6
isn't that really terrifying well once
white plays e6 that pawn is going to be
incredibly weak and we've got all these
pieces clustered in the center we don't
have to be afraid of that pawn on c6
okay so brad takes
we take back and notice that if white
plays knight takes d4 now we play knight
takes e5 and r knight then
simultaneously guards the c6 square and
our bishop comes out just in time to
defend
the e6 square otherwise there would be a
knight fork so if white takes on f6 we
take back with a bishop in order to keep
d4 protect i don't want to give away the
d4 pawn if we don't have to
we're going to try to cling to this pawn
if possible
now this pull this you know this might
not be the way we played here with f6
might not be great
uh but i think it's interesting and it's
and it's quite challenging
okay
it's quite possible that f6 is a mistake
it's quite possible that knight db8
is the best move and i think brad has
just played correctly there with with um
e6 there was one thing that i missed
yeah um
i missed one key detail unfortunately
but it's it's really not i don't think
it's the end of the world so what should
we do where should we go
um the issue is that
if we go knight c5 then we allow knight
takes d4
and then it's legitimately hard to get
to the e61 so i think what we should do
here
is get this knight instead to e5
now if white takes twice on e5 which is
not unlikely i mean brad might do that
then
the king on g1 is
not going to be very well defended i
mean there's going to be no more pieces
surrounding the king and i feel like if
we activate our bishops we'll be able to
get attacking chances against the king
we'll also get this open f-file for
for ourselves
i feel like
this is the best practical decision
there is a very unfortunate line that i
didn't fully account for
but we'll cross that bridge if we get
there
we'll cross that bridge if we get there
so brad taking taking his time
no i agree i mean practically speaking
the scotch gambit and brad plays
correctly yeah
yeah there was something i missed there
unfortunately i'm not
in the best form at the moment
so what what was i okay so we're gonna
have to go probably for a psac
which is very speculative but i don't
really see an alternative so what did i
miss
i thought that after c5 would just win
the pawn
i thought after c5 would just win the
plan unfortunately there's an insane
line here
that i failed to calculate i'm
quite sure brad will see it at this
point does anybody see what i'm talking
no not rook takes c5 or q5 there's just
f takes c5
now rookie 5 fp5 knight c6 queen d6
there's absolutely nothing
f4 is also completely innocuous we take
the knight and then we can take the pawn
on e6
knight c6 blunders the knight our knight
is still defending that square
knight f5 is the move
and the point is that after bishop takes
e6
does anybody see
the follow-up there i only calculate it
up until bishop takes c6
i don't know if i can really blame
myself for that too much because this is
a pretty crazy sequence
so knight f5 bishop takes e6
so a lot of you guys are saying f4 and
jumping the gun the knight is going to
be hanging on f5 knot knight takes g7
but knight takes e7
that looks dumb right why are you know
what's dangerous about that but after
queen takes e7
white has the move f4 i hope everybody's
still visualizing that position so
knight f5 bishop takes e6 knight takes
bishop queen takes knight and then white
plays f4 thank you routinian grand
master opinion for the raid
and
after we move our knight black white
plays f5 and wins our bishop somehow
um
so
this is actually trouble so i think it
makes sense to veer off
i think it makes sense to veer off
but
there's no good weight of your off
either
yeah i got completely outplayed
can i say
um
let's think
so i saw in that in that resulting
position of p sac we can give away the
knight for another pawn and then get a
big pawn center
it's not sound it's bad for black but it
presents
pretty decent practical chances i think
yeah we can also play g6 here which is
my second candidate mode g6 might
actually be the best move
g6 knight takes e7 queen takes c7
and although it's not
amazing we might also end up winning the
e6 pawn and then in that case everything
is justified
yeah let's go with g6 i think that's the
most prudent continuation black might
not even be worse here honestly
black might not even be worse here but
does everybody see what i missed
again bish i missed that after bishop
takes c6
knight takes c7 queen takes c7 there is
the move pawn f4 even though white has
nothing developed somehow we lose the
piece because we lose the move the
knight then white plays f5
and the rook on e1 is pinning the bishop
on e6
and there's another line there that's
even crazier i'll show that i'll show it
after the game
okay so knight h6 checked by brad see
this move i think might be a mistake i
preliminarily i don't know i didn't
consider this move at all
but it just seems to me that the knight
is stuck on the rim this is not
you know what conquered
this just doesn't seem that scary so
where should we go with our king well
definitely we should step up to g7 at
least making contact with the knight on
on h6 right that's not going to hurt in
addition
we know that after king h8 we create the
potential for a night fork on f7
why allow that extra source of tactical
uh problems right
okay so i gotta think for a second i
there's some
very interesting lines here to calculate
so this is a highly complex position
now um
there's a highly complex position
first of all i think it's important to
establish the knight cannot move at the
moment but if we play g5 to cut the
knight off then we give the knight the
monster f5 square so the most simple
move let's start with the simple one
what happens if we play bishop takes e6
well probably brad is going to take on
e5
we take back and then white takes on e5
again
and then our bishop on e6 is hanging
and in that resulting position we can
move our queen up to defend the bishop
but then brad will move his queen up to
e2 and both of my bishops are all of a
sudden gonna end up in trouble man some
of these tactics are just
pretty mind-boggling like i i can't
believe that
that some of this is causing us problems
but it is
now we might still have to go for that
line
because i don't see an alternative at
the moment
okay so i have to think about something
man it's like nothing works thanks takes
takes there no
hmm
so if we play queen d6 then there's
bishop f4
that's the problem windy 6 bishop f4
okay now i just have to think in silence
for a second
i think i know
what we have to do
it's very scary though
i do this with a heavy heart
we might get checkmated
i think what we need to do
is
just drop the knight back to c6
and i'll explain more after the game but
this is obviously a very serious game so
i i'm gonna have to do some things in
silence and some things i'm gonna have
to accelerate hope you guys understand
i promise that nothing will be left
unexplained like all of these weird
moves that i'm making i'll explain fully
after the game
thank you ground zero msq for this up
now one idea that we have here one idea
that we have here
is
to push this pawn up to d4
and who can tell me what the follow-up
is to that move why would we want to
push the pawn to d4
so ultimately our goal of course is to
win the e6 pawn in
a good version so d4 how do we follow up
we follow up with queen d5 this is a
classic idea right clearing the square
away with the pawn the square is
occupied by a pawn you want it to be
occupied by a piece so you push the pawn
forward and then you get your piece
there um we also are flirting with the
idea of going f5 and trapping the knight
on h6
so i'm expecting brad to drop this
knight back to g4
while he's still oh there's knight f7
jesus i completely missed that
i guess we have to cycle the exchange
now because after queen e8 bishop h6 we
lose the exchange
in an even worse version
yeah we have to take
that we have a pawn for the exchange
it's not the end of the world yeah this
is
brad is on another level this game
um this is not the end of the world
though it's not the position is not lost
it's we're worse no doubt about it but
not not losing and and still there
there's ideas of going before queenie
for some reason i completely forgot that
f7 is accessible to the knight
great developing move
threatens potentially bishop takes c7
i mean i think we should probably end up
going d4 and queen d5 anyway
yeah c3 is correct
i guess i mean this is losing but
yes queen d5 we can try
this is not resignable but it's lost i
mean if white is as accurate as he has
been there's no chances here
yeah i mean this is this is losing for
sure cdcd we gotta take
c7 is hanging i realized that that's
that the least of our problems is that
c7 is saying we got to get our pieces
out here i mean
we're down in exchange for
virtually no compensation
well the goal here is to develop our
pieces first i think we should start by
developing our pieces
and then see what happens i'm most
worried about brad just taking on c7
here i mean
a very classy even classier move would
be to go rook c1
that's like a gm of rook c1 just get the
rook onto a good square
and then we might want to fianchetto our
bishop instead at least try to create
some
you know inkling of tactical ideas down
the long diagonal
and maybe the time can become an issue
for him here although i i hate to win
speedrun games like on time like i
basically want to rule that out but
you know
obviously um queen b3 is possible so
some of you are looking at this saying
why doesn't white trade queens
queen b3 is possible but just because
you've got an end game doesn't mean that
um
you know that an extra exchange is going
to be that easy to convert
you know when b3 we could go bishop e6
for example
we still have a passer so even in the
end game it's not going to be elementary
for white 2 to convert this
extra exchange
i really want to analyze this game
because i
i was playing moves that i was
quite sure correct correct
but
clearly i did something wrong somewhere
okay well
we gotta go bishop b7
we gotta get this bishop out somewhere
and this is as good of a square as any
because it protects the knight on c6
no but this move is even better than
bishop takes c7 i mean you guys
okay and queen b3 no this is like
exquisite
um we have to take
yeah the problem is if we defend this
pawn we lose that pawn
so we might as well defend the d-pawn
that's the only
pawn that gives us any chances at all
and uh okay bishop c7 rook d7
we can keep trying i've saved worse
positions than this
you know in my in my career this is
salvageable
time is becoming a bit of an issue here
for white
it's a great move
that's a phenomenal move
no this
can go g5 maybe chase the bishop away
yeah i'm various i mean
to be completely honest i'm not all that
disappointed with my play i
i really don't feel like i didn't need
anything egregious
i i don't know where my mistake was
it seemed i mean maybe f6
in retrospect was a little over
ambitious maybe i should have gone
knight db8
but gosh this looks
like it has to be
i don't know
it's hard to say we'll we'll look with
an engine
now it's still not over i'm trying to
the way that i'm trying to approach this
position is
to take the magnus carlson method
basically of
uh one move at a time like you try to
create problems for your opponent on
every move
and survive one more move one more move
get the opponent low on time and
eventually
hopefully something is going to give so
for the moment if we lose the d4 pawn
then it's resignable
for the moment we still have the d4 pawn
so
for the moment we can still breathe
and perhaps we can even push the pawn on
d3 in order to support it with a knight
on b4
and you know he's starting to get a
little bit low on time
hopefully is right
yeah we're going to push d3 here
i'm going to push d3 here
and then we're going to try to support
it with the knight on v4 the only thing
that
the only consolation that i have here is
the fact that the bishop on g3
is somewhat out of the game
is somewhat out of the game
so if we can get this knight to b4 and
then if we can anchor that knight with
a5
i'm thinking that we're gonna have
practical chances in this position
even if we allow a trade of rooks
even if we allow a trader brooks which i
don't mind by the way i don't really
mind a trade of rooks as long as our
minor pieces stay quite active
this is annoying
we have to trade we have no choice
now let's try bishop d5 trying to get
the bishop to b3
okay
92
okay six to stop bishop d6
still i mean as long as i keep my my my
uh d-pawn alive the game is not over
which i'm gonna try to do here with
bishop e4
so there's turkey one
but then we play king d5 and defend the
bishop
it was king of one
i guess we can drop the bishop back we
can also go we can go knight c2 here
maybe
although then
bishop c3 maybe we can go knight d4
let's give it a shot
and that knight on c2 is pretty well
placed so maybe we can keep the knight
on c2
so what if we like maybe maybe what we
should do is drop this bishop back to g6
just do nothing i was thinking about
going 94 but if i do nothing
i don't see exactly how brad makes
progress here to be honest
he'll probably find some way but i don't
i don't see
i don't see exactly how white makes
progress here because we have this
knight on c2 that's guarding e1 and a1
so the rook cannot really activate
itself and as long as that's the case
we're chilling
i mean hope was hope has always been
there i i never
the position has never been hopeless
this has never been nearly
like totally lost it's been lost but
there's a difference between lost
objectively and
lost as in like there's no hope you
should resign
waiting moves so i mean there's nothing
else i can do there's no there's no
active moves i can make here
king d5 blunders the pawn
if we start pushing our pawns we take
away real estate from the bishop so the
move f5 would be a big mistake here
because of f3
okay knight d2
yeah now we can oh
okay now i'm seeing some some some good
stuff wait a second
now i'm seeing some some genuinely
decent stuff
so what is brad's idea first of all for
okay so i think what we can do here
i think brad is trying to go knight f3
and then maybe knight back to e1 which
is a very impressive idea
so
how can we stop that well we can try to
go
we can try to go g4
we can try to go g4
and try to clamp down as much as
possible in white's position
and all of a sudden our pieces have
become incredibly active so
i'm liking our chances here i'm
cautiously optimistic
brad also has a minute and a half i
there's no capability for me to add time
unfortunately so
even if i wanted to
okay and i think that's a mistake
i think that brad's maybe first mistake
of the game what does this allow
g3
and if f takes g3 we drop the knight
back with a fork and if he doesn't take
on g3 then we take on f2
gm's don't die hard to bring us down
this is already i think better for black
okay and i think brad is panicking
because
we play bishop takes f2 obviously
and now we've got mating ideas there's a
lot of stuff here going on
knight e3 is a mate threat white is one
defense i think
which he finds and that's knight c4
okay so amazingly
after king d5
white is b3
it's still not oh we're almost there but
it's not quite winning and if we go
bishop h5 we drop the pawn on d3
i think what we need to do here
is take a slow approach
to trying to win the game
rather than trying to do everything at
once we need to make
measured improving moves
so one thing that we could consider here
is to centralize the bishop with bishop
e4
just centralize the bishop aim at the g2
pawn and potentially prepare to push
this f pawn down white's throat if
possible
now remember again that
no matter what we do
what's helping us tremendously is the
fact that white's rook
is unable to activate itself via a1
because our knight controls that square
that's greatly freeing our task we don't
have to worry about white
all of a sudden you know getting
getting open here
we also have a tremendous threat in this
position that's kind of hidden
now remember that king d5 allows b3
but we don't only have the capability of
attacking the knight with the king we
have the capability of attacking it with
the bishop
so we're actually threatening
bishop d5 and brad
correctly plays b3
only move
only move i'm pretty sure
but now we can start pushing our pawn
down the board
well because now we flip if we play
bishop d5 why does rook takes d3 the
knight is protected
but i think what we need to do now
is start pushing the f1
bishop d2 also i think only move
now we can also get our king involved by
the way we can go king d5 and try to get
this king to d4
it's still very very hard to win this
let's go king d5 let's get this king
active
i'm thinking you know what i'm thinking
i'm thinking we can maybe get our king
all the way to d4
because why not
but is that really good though
we can also go knight g4
we can also go king c5 you know we can
also go king c5 and just try to win the
pawn with our king
i want to get this king up to d4
we want to get our king as active as
possible here
it's worried about that move
but i have an idea against it
and let me make this move now and then
i'll explain it later which is bishop e3
i mean there's nothing that needs
explaining i think in this move you can
see that i'm trying to
clear the pathway for my king
i mean it's a pretty obvious move i
think bishop e3 and if white plays
knight takes e4 then we're winning which
pay five is excellent but i don't know
if it works
so we can play king c5 here actually
maybe we can also play
bishop f4
and amazingly white goes knight c4
bishop t5
i think we're in good shape there
i think i think we're in good shape
after bishop f4
now we're threatening knight e3
only move and now we go bishop d5
in order to be able to take on
on c4 and go knight e3 check in which
case we'll win the rook and we'll be
winning this is exactly what i
calculated
there's a ridiculous line
there now we can i thought we could take
this actually
thought we could take this
sneak the king into c3
put more pressure on white's position
we've gotten this king as active as
possible
i don't see a defense for white at this
point i think he's losing but i'm not
sure
oh my god no there's a ridiculous oh my
goodness there's a crazy idea here for
white
no way
oh man
i've wondered another idea
huh
what's the conclusion there
he didn't find it he didn't find it
white had a ridiculous save rook takes
d3 check
king c4 rook c3 king b5 rook c2 and if
king a5 rook c5 winning the bishop it's
a draw now white should be
losing this has been i mean losing but
still not over because he still has
bishop b6
but then we have bishop e3 challenging
the bishop one more time
and i think we're
winding our tentacles around white's
pieces here
it's still not over but
sevens i mean brad is also dropping on
the clock here i think we should be able
to get him because
okay move make a move brad
okay he's gonna lose but this is already
lost this is already completely lost
because we're
we're just uh winning this pretty easily
here at this point
the evaluation at the end is okay we
have to let's just turn the engine on
straight away because there's so much to
discuss here
oh my god brad you're the freaking
you're a monster now you can see by the
way at the end that this is already lost
um
you played like a gym i mean you played
incredibly
i feel like i also found a lot of
resources but all credit to you
okay it was already winning mr akshat at
the end
so let's analyze now
the line that i'm familiar with here
okay castle's bishop b7
is bishop c6 rook uh
bc694
and now the move knight back to b8 thank
you brad you're a beast
and the point of knight b8 is that we we
want to go c5
and then get this knight back into the
game via c6
in addition we're preventing knight of
five this is theory
this is theory
um and you you know you're welcome to
acquaint yourself with
these lines
but this is this is theory with knight
b8 the move that i was not familiar with
i was not familiar with knight bd2 i
mean this is
apparently a move but i don't know it at
all castles and rookie one
okay so here
i think we made a very serious
misjudgment and i play them of f6 yeah
yeah you can see that
precisely because of the line in the
game white is now
quite a bit better
um
f6 is not a massive mistake but it's
it's too optimistic wow the best move
was a5 what
i've seen this move before in this line
i think the point is that you're trying
to grab space on the queen side
in preparation
for this position so the computer is
basically saying
if black does nothing so here's the
logic here's how i would try to explain
the logic if black does nothing and
passes the turn to white the computer is
basically saying that white has nothing
better
than to play bishop takes c6 and knight
takes d4
so
the computer's saying that we have
almost a it's like a false start has
been called in football and
tom brady you know has a free play
because the penalty is going to be
called anyway white's going to take on
c6 anyway so the computer plays a5 which
is a weird looking move but in the
context of this position it makes sense
to play a5 black is trying to grab space
on the queen side prevent the other
knight from getting to b3 and maybe
later to c5
and uh you know getting more space and
then playing c5
i don't know if that makes sense if
white plays a4 then that creates a
pretty big hole on b4 which is favorable
i think to black
but of course playing such a move in the
game is pretty wild
the alternative here that i considered
was knight d to b8 and i rejected it
because of knight b3 and i figured that
white takes the pawn here so i was
correct
in not liking this the other move
was was um and you can see it was giving
f6 initially but at a higher depth it it
rejects it
so basically knight c5 takes takes takes
and now queen up to d7 to defend the
pawn was also very much
viable for black
so either of these options was
either of these options was was possible
so anyways um
we played f6 and as i told you guys i
forgot that after e6
95
knight d4 and by the way notice that
knight takes e5 is very very bad for
white this position is already almost
lost because of bishop d6
and if the rook goes back to e1 black
develops
a massive attack against white's
extremely exposed king
i mean on a basic level white is so
badly developed here that he's neither
able to keep his king protected nor
able to keep the e6 pawn protected
so i think a lot of people would make
this mistake a lot of people here would
take twice on e5 and think oh i've got
this nice looking rook on e5 and i've
got the pawn and this is just like
missing the forest for the trees
if that makes sense forgetting that oh
well in reality what white's pieces are
very poorly coordinated undeveloped and
now the king on g1 is very exposed
so the move here is knight takes d4
so c5 is is
possible it's not a bad move knight f5
and now
bishop takes c6 loses a piece takes
takes and f4
this is the line that i was referencing
during the game and wherever the knight
goes white plays f5
and because of the pin black loses the
bishop does that mean and the amazing
thing this is what i implied i would
show after the game bishop g4 at first i
was very excited oh this traps the queen
but no queen takes g4
and the queen on e7 is undefended and
knight f3 check oh well at least we win
the rook anyone no we don't knight takes
f3 and the work is protected there's
literally not a single resource here
black just loses a piece
which is pretty wild
so for that reason we decided to veer
off and play g6
and now brad responds correctly so i
only considered
knight takes c7 check up to which black
has a pretty decent position
but brad found this idea knight h6 and
down knight f3
and here i was unable to to find
apparently the only move which is queen
d6
and what after bishop f4
wow queen b6 jesus
just leaving the king to fend for itself
though apparently this was the only way
to preserve a a playable position
but i mean this also gives up the plot
on d5
this is a pretty ridiculous like
computer idea queen d6 queen b6 like
walking right into bishop f4 yeah so
so knight c6 right why did i play knight
c6
basically i
first of all i missed knight f7
i thought that i would be able to play
d4 queen d5 and eventually maybe win the
pawn i only considered knight g4 and now
i thought after g5 okay the position
remains very complicated
but like obviously white threatens to
take twice on e5 so
something has to be done with the knight
on e5 and it's unclear what to do
because
this allows knight takes c5
and then queen takes d5
so i figured dropping the knight back is
the best option but yeah after knight f7
i correctly gave up the exchange it's
the only move
bishop f4
d4
c3 is very strong as well queen d5 is
good
cd
okay according to the engine knight
takes d4 might have been a slightly
better option
d c d
rook c one is good this should be seven
is correct queen b3 so queen b3 is
actually inaccurate by brad he's played
this almost perfectly so far but queen
b3
uh as i told you guys
you shouldn't go out of your way to
trade queens in
positions where the queens aren't
necessarily favoring your opponent i
think white should have simply taken on
c7 now you can see that it's plus 1.67
it's not like okay it's not resignable
it's not nearly resignable
but it's very bad i mean rook c8 bishop
back to g3 and as long as white can keep
this pawn contained
the white is an extra exchange and white
should be able to win the game
but okay
so brad goes queen b3
we took it
and i correctly played rook d8 i was
actually quite happy that i found this
idea just r8 giving away the c7 pawn and
focusing putting all of our eggs in the
d4 pawn basket
so rook c4
rook c4 is very good
now i play g5 also correct bishop c7 or
d7 bishop g3 and at this point d3 is
correct
i played this stretch very well so
knight b4 is not best bishop before
apparently was
was better um to protect the d2 square
and not patting myself on the back or
anything
hashtag arrogance i don't understand g5
so g5
essentially forces the bishop to decide
what to do well i'm trying to take away
the f4 square from the bishop
first of all i'm provoking bishop takes
c7 and i don't want the bishop to be
able to return to f4 why is that
important because the f4 square and this
diagonal in general allows the bishop to
keep the pawn constrained does that make
sense when the bishop comes back to g3
it's pretty much locked up on g3 it
cannot rejoin the game through f4
so that's one less piece that white can
put in charge of guarding this pawn
yeah so brad
plays rook d1 knight before now rook c7
is very good yeah now we get this end
game bishop d5
knight d2 bishop c5
knight c4 is very strong
king e6 bishop a5 bishop i mean we're
playing all the tops here king f1
knight c2 bishop c3
bishop back to g6 so you can see that
white is better but the computer is not
seeing anything like super concrete here
and now g4 is very important to prevent
knight f3
well you push past pawns h3 and h3 is is
finally the breaking point after g3
we're already much better
before bishop f2 and knight c4 and here
i probably didn't find
the best way to win i just want to go to
the end for a second
and show brad your defensive resource
so already here we're winning
but i messed up
oh apparently king e4 is still winning
here
apparently king e4 is still winning in
this position
but the resource was rook takes d3 check
king takes c4 rook c3 check
now it might you might say well wait a
minute the king just drops back and
attacks the bishop but after rook takes
c2
if you take the bishop you get forked
again thank you cram box for the prime
so this was a crazy resource that could
have saved the game at the very end
i mean maybe not save the game because
black can drop the king around to e4 and
this is a highly complex end game but
because black is so active here
black should be winning so i could
analyze this end game for like an hour
i am getting really exhausted though i
it's like i'm
i can barely formulate my sentences so
i'm thinking that maybe i can take a
rain check on analyzing this particular
end game
i'll i'll analyze a little bit on my own
and maybe present some
key ideas next stream
let's check the i i'm just curious to
see
what our accuracies were i think this
was a pretty high level game overall
oh why does it do this it just doesn't
oh there we go
yeah not as as great as i thought
so i ended up winning but
because brad
played knight d2 check
king a4 bishop b6 and at this point
already the game is over
first thing to
to note is that um
as i said
when europe material i think one of the
greatest myths
that's over
overstated
not sinatra with a thousand bits
is this concept that you always have to
train when you're up and if you know if
you miss a chance at simplification
that's automatically a mistake not true
at all
so in this position black's king is
weaker than whites and you can tell that
just by the pawn structure around
black's king right we've got all this
damage that's done and white's up in
exchange for god's sake
so there is no need to trade queens here
trading queens actually gives this past
pawn on d4 a little bit more life
the more pieces on there's an inverse
inverse um
correlation between
how many pieces are left on the board
and how effective a past pawn is
if you take everything off the board
then a passport is a potential game
winner
if you know it's a middle game this pass
pawn is going absolutely nowhere it's
never going to make its way past d3
because white's protecting that with 300
pieces does that make sense so for that
reason brad should have taken on c7 here
and then move the bishop back either to
g3 but i would prefer to put it on f4
again to protect the d2 square
so
queen b3 gives us quite a bit of life
so rook d8 now rookie is another
important move i think quite a few
people
and the computer is calling it a mistake
but i
you can see that there's a contradiction
between
it giving it a mistake but if you give
it more time
i think it actually ends up
um i think it actually ends up
liking it more
at a higher depth yeah i think rook d8
is one of the better moves
and i think quite a few people here
probably would go rook c8
which is not
a horrible move but it's way too passive
right you can't but
you can't burden yourself with the c7
pawn this pawn on c7 is not this is
irrelevant to the game
the only relevant thing is whether black
is going to be able to keep the d4 pawn
so everything that i do
from here on out in the next 10 moves
was in one way or another
aimed at either preserving or increasing
the uh intensity of the d4 pawn
including the move rook d8
and then the move g5 which is aimed at
taking away the f4 square from white's
bishop
and as you can see the top computer
recommendation
is actually not to take on c7 but to
drop the bishop back to d2 in order to
keep this pawn blockaded
so that's kind of interesting right
bishop c7 so natural
but after the bishop is
x communicated to
like siberia it can never go back to f4
again as long as the pawn remains on g5
so d3
now we push the pawn
now we push the pawn why are we pushing
the pawn well
past pawns are meant to be pushed right
here i judged
that the pawn on d3
is going to be
safe because the knight can jump to b4
if needed the bishop can come out to a6
if needed
and you know the further along upon is
the more it strains the opponent's
resource so d3
rook d1
and now knight before apparently
possibly inaccurate and i saw that it
allows a rook trade but i figured the
most important thing is to keep this
pawn protected
but according to the engine the best
move was bishop b4 now what is the idea
of this move who can explain
why why put a bishop on before why not a
knight i mean knight on b4 makes a lot
of intuitive sense because it protects
the pawn
but what's the point of putting a bishop
there why is this the best move
well it's to control the d2 square right
knight before defends the pawn bishop
before controls the square in front of
the pawn
now does black necessarily want to play
d2 on the next move probably not it's
probably premature like let's say white
plays h3
what black should do here is secure the
bishop with a5 just so we don't have to
worry about it and
the pawn on d3 is perfectly safe it's
essentially inaccessible i mean the only
way to attack it is to play knight e1
but now black can already take this
knight that's why we put the bishop on
b4
and then wow look at this beautiful idea
the computer is giving bishop a6
and this is what happens when past
spawns reach the third rank you get a
lot of these tactical ideas that are
connected with sacrificing other pieces
and then promoting your past spawn or
forcing your opponent to give away a lot
of pieces for it this makes a draw
because white must give up his rook for
the passer
that's a cool idea that's a byproduct of
you know the pawn reaching d3
and so knight before apparently is a
mistake because it allows the rook trade
okay so now bishop d5
and the idea of bishop d5 is to attack
the pawn on b3
and force white
to go a little bit more passive
now bishop c5 to activate the bishop and
pin the f dupont
and brad played a very nice move knight
c4 getting this knight on an anchor
point and opening up more pressure on
the d3 punt
okay now i brought my king up to e6 and
this is a very concrete idea who can
remind me what i'm preventing by playing
king e6 because white does have a threat
potentially what is the threat here what
is it
no already bear asked why i didn't take
on f3 i'll explain that in a second
so what is white threatening what
squares is this knight coppering bishop
d6 right bishop d6 good as we're paying
attention bishop d6 is a huge threat
because it forces the trade and now the
rooks off the board every subsequent
trade is in white's favor because black
just doesn't have a lot of pieces to go
around
now you might look at this well is
doesn't bishop take c4 win a piece well
no it doesn't because white takes on c5
bishop takes b3 rook d2 and the pawn on
d3 is lost because the knight you cannot
keep the knight on b4
okay
oh and this is really cool knight a6
rook takes d3 anyway
knight c5 rook c3 and white wins
uh white wins the piece back and wins
the game crazy how am i how many tactics
there are in these types of positions so
for that reason
oh artie was asking why i didn't take on
f3 so that's exactly the same reason
when you have so few pieces you can
every subsequent trade is really really
bad because now white's going to play
bishop a5
and disattach the knight from the pawn
and just win the pawn you actually need
your your light square bishop uh in
order to potential in order to act as a
potential defender of this one does that
make sense
i already bear you asked the question so
i don't know if my explanation made
sense that
okay so bishop d3 bishop d5 bishop c5
king e6
bishop a5
now brad was threatening to take and
then to take
okay so we played whatever we played we
played bishop e4
defending the pawn and that's why the
bishop on e4
that's why we needed to keep the light
square bishop alive
king f1 and by the way rookie 1 is not
as dangerous as it looks because we can
play either f5 or king d5 and the bishop
is perfectly safe
so king f1 we go knight c2 and i think
this is the turning point in the game i
honestly think that once we put the
knight on c2 things got a lot harder for
white thank you cass things got a lot
harder for white because the rook is now
completely confined
it cannot get active
and although the computer effortlessly
maneuvers around this
uh even you can see even the engine at a
pretty high depth doesn't feel like
white is all that much winning
and possibly even white is not winning
at all 1.5 in such a position might mean
that yes white is up in exchange but
that generally means the computer
doesn't see an exact path forward
why move his king and not take your
knight with bishop takes before
that's a good question so
i felt like the two bishops are very
strong here one of them defends the pawn
the other controls the squares in front
of it
it's quite difficult for white to make
any progress here
so this specific piece tandem the two
bishops are the best that black can get
i know i just said that every subsequent
trade is beneficial to white
but this is the one exception because
these bishops are incredibly active
why couldn't white have gone 91 earlier
to target the d-pawn
so i'm
do you mean here because here we can
take on b3 attacking the rook
and then drop the bishop back to c4 to
defend the pawn so i don't think there
was a good opportunity for white to play
knight e1
i don't think so i mean white could have
played 91 here but again this is not
very impressive because white's not even
attacking the pawn
okay so hopefully that was
adequately explained king f1 knight c2
bishop c3 so now we drop our bishop back
to g6 and this is where i reference the
sort of russian school of chess just do
not move back and forth well black
doesn't have anything that he can do
like we can't really do anything
i'm not you obviously can't push the
pawn white doesn't have any easily
accessible targets so i was basically
planning just to go back and forth with
my bishop maybe also push the king side
pawns and grab a little bit of space
maybe make it even harder for white to
to make moves does that makes so this is
a very important ability right in the
end game
to to be able to say okay
like i've reached a situation where i
think everything is well defended if
you're trying to make a draw
knowing when to do nothing is a very
important skill so bishop g6
and now i want to draw your attention to
one of the to the computer's top
recommendation which is a ridiculously
instructive move
b4
is the computer's top choice look at
that move
who can explain to me the idea why are
we so why is white sacrificing the pawn
like what what the heck
to activate the rook piece activity is
so important in the end game this allows
the rook to squeeze by through a1
and if we go back to c2 well it's
already too late the rook has now gotten
active along the a file
and why is that important well because
blacks
without a rook black's minor pieces have
a hard time keeping things together
right if you go king d5
b3 and now the bishop is pinned and the
pawn is hanging and things start to
crumble at the seams
so
of course black can decline the
sacrifice and move this bishop back but
now there is a crazy idea b3
and then knight back to b2 in order to
win the pawn that way
for example here knight b2
knight takes b4 bishop takes b4 bishop
takes before knight takes d3 white has
succeeded taking the pawn the game is
not over black has very active pieces
and black can still try to make a draw
here but without the plan i think it
would be very difficult
what a ridiculous idea b4
then b3 and knight back to b2 are you
kidding me
and people say end games are boring
b4
look at how many components there are to
this this is also a sacrifice with the
idea of activating the rook if the sack
is declined the knight is fianchettoed
with the aim of winning the pawn on d3
the engine is ridiculous yeah unfindable
so brad dropped the knight back to d2
which allowed us to clamp further onto
white's position g4 stopping knight f3
now you might ask
why was knight f3 dangerous well the
reason it was dangerous to allow knight
f3
is because from f3 the knight can swing
back to e1 attacking the d3 pawn or
forcing a trade and the last piece that
we want to trade this knight on c2 is
the golden piece
it's totally limiting the rook so we
don't want it to get traded
hopefully everything is making a fair
degree of sense so far so we play g4 to
stop knight f3 and here brad kind of
collapses and plays h3 so as you can see
according to the computer knight should
have gone back to c4 and then white
could have reverted back to the idea of
b4 but this tells you how hard it is to
win this endgame already at this point
so h3 g3
and b4
is a further mistake i think that
probably the most practical chance for
white was to take on g3 here actually
and allow knight e3 check and go king e1
now here black can take the rook but it
makes sense to take the pawn first
and then drop the knight back to e3 this
is the same version just with an extra
pawn
and if you take on d1 black has great
winning chances here but
i think that probably this was
objectively the best drawing chance for
white
but brad goes before allowing bishop
takes up two at first i thought the game
is over immediately because we have
checkmate threat
but
knight c4 only move
and it's not so easy
and if
you know king d5
then b3 and i didn't see a clear path
forward
but apparently according to the engine
there is a winning move here either
bishop d4 or even knight back to d4
attacking b3
and if bishop takes d4 after after king
takes d4 black is already winning
why is black winning here because first
of all white's king is totally caged in
second of all there's a massive threat
of bishop h5 bishop e2 checkmate
black's pieces are overwhelming here
this pawn is too far advanced the king
is too active there's a mate threat
white is unable to hold everything
together hopefully that makes sense
there's just too many sources of
problems here so the move here was 94
for some reason i didn't spot knight d4
i kind of stopped at this position
yeah always bring your king up this is a
good illustration of how important it is
to keep the king active so i played
bishop e4
and the reason i played bishop b4 was to
try to get this bishop back to d5
and get this knight off of c4 so that we
could deliver checkmate
but i totally forgot about b3
and now bishop d5
is too late rook takes d3 and now white
is winning
because this is no longer checkmate
obviously because of king e2
so
now black has to find another way
to make progress and so i decided on f5
i tried to get this pawn forward and try
to push it all the way to f3 in order to
create another passer but brad beats me
to the punch again bishop back to d2
stopping f4
so this is where i decided to activate
my king king d5
and now brad plays b5
now again you can see that the
computer's evaluations at a high depth
don't always correspond to what the top
is saying
but here apparently already black's
advantage has largely evaporated if
white goes bishop f4 i think white's got
a fortress here is what the computer is
saying i think white has a fortress here
well bishop takes g2 doesn't work
because the knight on c4 is defending e3
i think basically white has a fortress
here
and remember that as soon as white takes
on b4 that as soon as black takes on
before white's rook immediately goes to
a1 and gets active
so it's just incredibly hard for black
to make any progress here
a fortress is a situation well just like
a fortress in real life right it's it's
something that's it's a position that is
impossible to break through
in which it is impossible to break
through so it usually implies a draw a
fortress is a situation where one side
has built up a defensive construction
that is impossible
to infiltrate or penetrate so you can't
make progress
yeah i mean of course some positions
genuinely are fortresses and this is
probably one of them but brad by going
b5 allows us to get our king active king
d4
and now it's too late to go bishop f4
because we've already breached the
fortress with our king
so knight d6 bishop e3 now what's the
idea of bishop b3 well it's to capture
on d2 and pave the way for the king to
move to c3
now we get that bishop back to f4 which
is apparently not the best move
better was to play f4 and f3 and revert
back to my old plan
and here
bishop d5 b6 and apparently the winning
move here was bishop take c4
bc
and now simply a takes b6 and then king
takes e4 and we get a similar situation
to what we've discussed previously
overwhelming
this is just overwhelming
but instead of this i for some reason
took on b6 and went king c3
completely forgetting about this final
drawing resource rook takes d3 check
and then rook c3 check
artibia was asking
bishop takes c4 bishop takes a7 oh if
bishop takes c4 ba7 then simply bishop
back to d5 stopping the pawn
and if b7 well that doesn't threaten
anything because the other bishop guards
b8
now i saw bishop takes c4 but for some
reason i only considered knight e3 check
and after king g1 if you play knight
takes d1 white wins b takes a7 and now
the pawn is unstoppable
so a lot of tricks even here but here i
missed the com a takes b6 i just forgot
that you can do that
so
one final chance for brad here rook
takes d3 check which i already
illustrated but once he missed that our
king gets back to a4 we go bishop b3
this is already winning for black
just because i mean this is already
overwhelming white has no more pawns
left and this gets
one way or another we're going to get a
knight to e3 or pawn to f3 this is
winning
wow
okay i now i'm a little bit more
satisfied at the way we analyze the end
game so i hope you guys found that
somewhat informative
we barely scratched the surface i'm sure
there's a lot more disgust this was one
of the
most complicated and most interesting
games i've probably ever had on the
speedrun so
thank you brad
you're you're the man of the hour thank
you guys thank you for hanging out
everybody this was great i'll see you
later bye everybody
[Music]
you